yes it's finally been confirmed for real
now the iPhone 15 Pro will be getting an
action button which will replace the
ringer switch and I apologize in advance
but I told you so over a week ago I made
this video saying that the action button
is confirmed for the 15 Pro where I put
all the puzzle pieces and leaks together
and it just made sense well now we got
confirmation from a hugely reputable
source that says he has an inside guy
within Apple who confirmed not only the
action button but the specific details
on how the brand new solid state haptic
volume and power buttons will work even
when your iPhone is dead so let's jump
into all these leaks before I explain
why apple is even doing this in the
first place now the league is from
Anonymous ad on Mac Rumors forums who is
actually the same guy who confirmed the
new pill-shaped Dynamic Island last year
in August before the September event so
he definitely has a really good so
course and as for today's leak he even
said to not take the info with the grain
of salt with this leak being fully
definite and it even matches the other
various cads that were leaked so I fully
believe he's right the first thing he
confirmed was that the iPhone 15 Pro
will replace the mute ringer switch that
iPhones have had since the original
iPhone with a brand new action button
this idea was first speculated about
when some new cads were released over a
week ago showing off this new button the
idea here is that you'll be able to
fully customize and program this button
to do many different actions like
opening various apps functions switching
between modes like low power mode or
light and dark mode or even triggering
custom shortcuts Joe resignal for Mac
rumors mentioned that it's essentially
the back tap feature that we've had
already but integrated directly into
this new action button and then if you
want to mute you would simply long press
the button to mute your iPhone or maybe
Apple will allow you to customize both
short and long presses I think this is
an excellent idea from Apple because
right now all it does is mute your phone
and some people like myself always keep
it muted and basically never touch the
switch unless I'm anxious or bored and
need something to fidget with now the
other part of the leak is some really
awesome specifics on how the new action
volume and power buttons will work
specifically because we know they're
getting replaced with solid state
buttons that don't actually move or
click at all each side is going to have
a taptic engine built in that vibrates
to make it feel just like a real click
Apple has actually been doing this for
years with the solid state Touch ID
button that's still present today on the
iPhone SE as well as their MacBook Force
touch track pads which are the best in
the business and yes Ming Chico already
confirmed that only the new iPhone 15
Pro Models will be getting these new
buttons and there will be two new taptic
engines while the regular iPhone 50 teen
will continue to only have one now the
only problem with these solid state
buttons is that they don't work at all
when the device is off or when the
battery dies but guess what this Mac
Rumors leaker has just confirmed
apparently his inside source of Apple's
Dev team has confirmed that the iPhone
15 Pro Models will come with a new
microprocessor that will replace Apple's
current super low energy mode which is
currently built into the main chip now
if you didn't already know that low
energy mode already allows you to do
certain small tasks on current iPhones
like using Apple pay when your iPhone is
dead or being able to track the location
of your iPhone yes when it is dead which
is a super impressive feature now
apparently the new microprocessor will
allow the new solid state buttons on the
15 Pro Models to function perfectly
including button presses holds and 3D
touch detection even when your phone is
powered down own or dead that was
essentially the only concern people had
when Ming Chico leaked this information
about the buttons a while back and it
looks like apple has solved it not only
that but it's even being tested with and
without taptic engine feedback so it
might even click and vibrate when it's
powered off but he's not 100 sure now we
also mentioned that this new microchip
will take on the find my Bluetooth Ultra
wide band and Apple pay Express card
features while the phone is off which
will greatly improve power consumption
meaning that these features will last
for even longer than they currently do
after your phone is off or it dies so
here's a helpful screenshot that
explains exactly what will work during
each scenario and as for the volume
buttons the inside man says that there
are two possible options for how they'll
work with the first one being based on
how hard you press each side of the
volume rocker making volume increase or
decrease quicker and the other one is
being able to swipe up and down on the
volume rocker itself which by the way is
now one long volume rocker instead of
individual buttons so it could adjust
the volume just like that which is
actually exactly how the airpods Pro 2
work right now so it's going to be easy
for Apple to reuse the same software
from the airpods and bring it to the new
volume slider on the iPhone 15 Pro
Models The Source just isn't sure which
method will be used right away or if
it's going to be enabled during an iOS
17 software update later on after these
phones get released now the big question
people have right now is how is it going
to work with cases and I think the force
touch side buttons will be just fine
since they're going to be very sensitive
but I don't think the swipe up and down
features will work with cases that cover
up the entire phone and the buttons so
if Apple decides to add the swiping
features to the volume rocker expect all
iPhone 15 Pro cases to have huge cutouts
where the volume button is for swiping
up and down just like this case right
here and finally let's answer the
question of why Apple would make this
change first of all Apple does major
iPhone chassis redesigns every three
years and this change is pretty cool and
very unique since no other Android phone
offers a feature like this solid state
buttons that work very very well and
another reason is that the physical
buttons we currently have right now do
actually wear down losing their
clickiness over time especially the mute
switch and sometimes the buttons stop
working all together so this redesign
will fix those issues now on top of that
solid state buttons will actually help
with further waterproofing since there
are no cracks or gaps whatsoever
reducing the chance that water will get
into it when you're in deep water now
the removal of the SIM card tray is
already having that effect in the US and
I think over the next couple of years
they're going to remove it globally and
why would Apple do this well I
personally believe that Apple wants to
create a fully waterproof phone even in
salt water yes the saltwater ocean just
like the Apple watch does right now and
the only way that's going to happen is
that if Apple seals off all the gaps by
getting rid of the SIM card tray getting
rid of the physical buttons which
they're doing this year and of course
getting rid of the port which is going
to be USBC which I think they're going
to do in three years when it's time to
fully redesign the phone again in 2026.
now the crazy thing is that Apple has
been working on patents where the
touchscreen will actually work when
underwater and the patent images even
show off recording underwater in the
ocean at Mavericks California which is a
popular surfing location so that is why
I think apple is going to create a fully
waterproof iPhone in 2026 using the
magsafe wireless charging feature
exclusively for charging and the first
step towards that goal is of course
getting rid of the physical buttons and
the SIM card tray this will make it the
most unique smartphone in the world
making people feel very confident with
the waterproofing because if it can
handle salt water in the ocean it should
have zero issues with a simple rinse
under the sink to clean off any sticky
spills or anything like that and that
right there is gonna make it sell from
Apple's marketing perspective so with
that said I think the iPhone 15 Pro will
be a huge deal and the perfect time to
upgrade your iPhone so go ahead and
share your thoughts down below and click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
thank you
[Music]